good evening and welcome to tucker
carl's tonight there are not a lot of
amazing stories left in the new york
times they're also predictable and
self-righteous but if you read the paper
yesterday you did see one u.s exposes
what it says is russian effort to
fabricate pretext for invasion
that was the headline the story
explained that at some point very soon
vladimir putin plans to stage a fake
military attack on his own citizens
putin will use actors to portray
ukrainian soldiers and intel operatives
committing atrocities against russians
then he's gonna videotape the whole
thing and secretly release it to the
world
when people in the west see the clips of
that on facebook they'll understand why
putin was justified in invading ukraine
so it's a psyop
that was the claim pretty diabolical
but you may be wondering how exactly do
we know that vladimir putin is actually
planning to do something like this
because in real life the global
intelligence world is a very complicated
place people in it rarely tell
straightforward truths
so actually if you were devising
propaganda for the ukrainian government
this might be exactly the kind of story
you would place in the new york times
which of course is compliant they're on
your side
a story like this would give you a way
to plausibly deny attacking russian
citizens
is that what happened here well we don't
know we have no idea if the new york
times account is true or not then again
neither does the new york times
right in the story the paper conceded
that the biden officials quote would not
release any direct evidence of the
russian plan or specify how they learned
of it saying to do so would compromise
their sources and methods
of their sources and methods
those must be the same sources and
methods the ci is protecting by
continuing to hide thousands of
documents from 911 two decades ago
or from the kennedy assassination almost
60 years ago sources and methods
if you live in washington you reckon
that is recognized that as the
all-purpose justification for everything
state department spokesman ned price
knows exactly how this works because
price began his career at the cia
watch ned price at the briefing
yesterday
we have previously noted our strong
concerns regarding russian
disinformation and the likelihood that
moscow might create seek to create a
false flag operation to initiate
military activity
now we can say that the united states
has information that russia is planning
to stage fabricated attacks by ukrainian
military or intelligence forces as a
pretext for a further invasion of
ukraine wait a second ned price what was
that a false flag operation really
that's a jarring term to hear from a joe
biden employee much less an official
because until yesterday we were under
the impression that false flag
operations didn't exist and they said
they did exist it was only within the
diseased imaginations of conspiracy
theorists like alex jones and his
minions in q and that's what they told
us
but now they're telling us that false
flag operations are entirely real except
they never happen here never in the
united states never in washington only
in russia
okay we'll let that digest for a minute
cia veteran ned price assures us it's
true
now normally that would have been the
end of it reporters would have scurried
back to their cubicles to write their
breathless little stories about vladimir
putin's latest false flag operation and
by and large that's exactly what did
happen the stenographers wrote ned
price's story
but one of them didn't
that man's name is matt lee he's a state
department reporter for the associated
press we know nothing about matt lee
other than he appears to be a
middle-aged man who's been around long
enough to ask a skeptical follow-up
question or two and in washington that
makes him virtually unique lee noticed
that ned price hadn't actually said
anything that could be checked or even
described in meaningful detail
so lee asked hey ned price what exactly
are you talking about
here's the exchange that followed
okay well that's a quite a mouthful
there
so you said actions such as these
suggest otherwise suggest meaning that
they suggest they're not interested in
talks and they're going to go ahead with
some kind of
what action are you talking about
one the actions i've just pointed to uh
the the fact that russia continues to
engage uh in disinformation uh campaign
made an allegation that they might do
that have they actually done it uh what
we know matt is what we what i have just
said that they have engaged in this
activity
in this planning activity but let me let
me because because obviously this is not
this is not the first time we've made
these reports public
whoa whoa whoa hold on a second what are
you talking about that was the question
and it's a good question you wish you
heard it more in official briefings in
fact you wish you heard it more in
everyday life in this country it's
usually the essential question and the
first step toward finding out what the
truth is ned price of course didn't want
to answer that question but lee kept
pressing him
why didn't matt lee just take ned
price's word for it like everybody else
well maybe because this is the very same
ned price who has a documented history
of lying to reporters in the briefing
room here's ned price promising that
kabul would not fall to the taliban not
long before it did fall to the taliban
the president from the day he
announced that the u.s military would be
withdrawing except for
the troops necessary to protect our
diplomatic compounds was very clear that
we have partnered with the afghan people
and with the afghan government over the
course of some 20 years now
that partnership would not diminish in
any way
with the withdrawal with the military
withdrawal
from afghanistan
again
we retain a diplomatic compound in kabul
that
is what we
intend to retain going forward
settle down reporters our partnership
with the afghan government will not
diminish in any way with the military
withdrawal from afghanistan quote
so days after ned price said that the
biden-backed president of afghanistan
threw millions of u.s dollars into a
duffel bag and fled to the uae in a
private plane
so actually the partnership did diminish
pretty quickly in fact matt lee has been
around long enough to remember that
probably also remembers the time that
colin powell promised the country there
were no wmd there were wmd in iraq when
there weren't probably remembers the
time hillary clinton claimed our
ambassador in benghazi was murdered over
an islamic phobic youtube video he may
remember those two separate occasions
not so long ago when the entire foreign
policy establishment in washington
assured us that evil bashar al-assad had
gassed his own people with poisoned gas
and deserved to be bombed
but at the same time forgot to show us
any evidence that it actually happened
we're still waiting on that evidence by
the way
matli appears to remember stuff like
that and he mentioned it yesterday
ned i've been doing this for you i know
that was my point you you have no you
have been doing this for quite a while
you know that when we declassify
intelligence information we do so in a
means
we do so we do so with an eye to
protecting sources and methods not gonna
fall
i remember a lot of things so where
where is the declassified information
other than you coming out here and
saying
best question ever where is the
classified information other than you
coming out here and saying it
how thrilling to watch someone ask
something so simple imagine if the
entire press corps behaved like that we
might have a decent government ned price
for his part seemed completely
unprepared for any of this and highly
annoyed by it nothing in his ca cia
training had suggested he might
encounter disobedient reporters in the
briefing room at the state department
so he stuck with what he had which was i
said it therefore it's true
here he is
we told you a few weeks ago that we have
information indicating russia also has
already prepositioned a group of
operatives to conduct a false flag
operation in eastern ukraine so that
matt to your question is an action that
russia has already taken it's an action
that you say that they have taken but
you have shown no evidence to
to to confirm that
so went on and on like this four minutes
we're not going to play the whole thing
if you really want to dislike your
government you can look it up for
yourself online we can tell you that ned
price's superciliousness gets more
nauseating as it goes on doesn't make
you wonder about the cia do they hire
people this oily on purpose
where do they find them well the
georgetown school of foreign service of
course
we'll play just one more portion of this
exchange in which mattley flips the
usual script and accuses ned price of
sounding like a crazed conspiracy nut
it's beautiful watch
what is the evidence that they i mean
this is like crisis actors really this
is like alex jones territory you're
getting it too now
um
what evidence do you have to support the
idea that there is some propaganda film
in the in in the making
matt this is derived uh from information
known to the us government intelligence
information that we have declassified i
think you okay well where is it where
where is this information it is
intelligence information that we have
declassified well where is it where
where's the declassified information i
just delivered it
no you made a series of allegations
[Laughter]
one correction alex jones lies far less
and is far more credible than ned price
is but you see the point ned price lost
that exchange he claimed to have
information that he did not have
and matt lee persistently called him out
on it so ned price just ran out of bs
the bs barrel was empty
so what did he do then
what did ned price do then you know the
answer ned price did what they all do
when they're cornered he went right to
the lowest personal attack he didn't
call matt lee racist he's probably
saving that for next week but he did
suggest that matt lee is more
sympathetic to russia than he is to his
own country the united states he implied
that matt lee is a shill for vladimir
putin watch
if you doubt the the credibility of the
u.s government of the british government
of other governments and want to
you know find uh solace and information
that the russians are putting out
that is that is for you to do i'm not
asking what the russian government is
putting out and
what is it supposed to be so if you're
on russia's side
now in an earlier age this is the point
where matt lee would have vaulted the
podium and punch ned price right in the
face there was a time in this country
when calling a man disloyal was a grave
and serious charge you could not let
that stand
that's not true anymore we're so used to
it now we hear it constantly on
wednesday two days ago during a
closed-door briefing in congress on
russia jim cooper of tennessee a
democrat asked an intelligence briefer
to find out if this show is tied to
russia
we're not tied to russia of course as a
cable television program we're not a
diplomatic mission jim cooper needless
to say knows that
but that's not the point the point is
we've criticized the biden
administration's ukraine policy so in
retaliation for that jim cooper has
asked the intel agencies to dig up dirt
on us to be clear that's not allowed
it's illegal it is illegal to use the us
government to settle partisan scores or
to silence opposition journalists it is
also by the way illegal to secretly
monitor their electronic communications
but joe biden's nsa did that to this
show this summer that happened we're not
speculating about it the nsa admitted it
and congressman cooper admitted what he
did today when we asked him though he
was too cowardly to come on the show
tonight to explain how he could justify
that
this is scary behavior it's also
revealing after a full year of governing
all the biden administration can muster
when challenged are ad hominem attacks
and more spying from the intel agencies
let's put the intel agencies on them
what they can't do is explain themselves
they don't even try
that's not a sign of strength it's a
sign of rot it's a sign of weakness
and yet they're doing it and they're
getting away with it how are they
getting away with it very simple
they're getting away with it because
republicans are allowing them to get
away with it
screaming about russia even as we ignore
china is now a bipartisan effort
you remember russiagate you thought
republicans would never fall for that
again no they internalized the whole
thing they now believe that russia is
our greatest enemy they're the
existential threat all eyes on putin
they could stop this tomorrow if mitch
mcconnell criticized the build-up to war
with putin it would end immediately if
five republicans the united states
senate held a press conference tomorrow
to declare that the territorial
integrity of the united states is more
important than the territorial integrity
of ukraine
this couldn't continue the lunacy would
end
but they're not doing that
instead republicans are every bit as
hysterical about russia
as adam schiff ever was
watch
so we do need to go ahead and impose
sanctions on russia now we need to show
them that we mean business and we will
be there for ukraine do you think
president joe biden should send us
troops to eastern europe
without delay it appears to me the
administration's moving in the right
direction there needs to be clear
consequences for what they do because we
failed to deter and now you're inviting
conflict it's it's a it's a very bad
situation and we've and we've left
ourselves without many options as a
result i don't think we're providing the
deterrents necessary to stop putin from
invading ukraine as putin tries to
dismantle nato and divide nato i support
president biden's decision to send more
troops in to reinforce nato
so lindsey graham admits that i'm on
biden's side but most of them are too
clever to do that
they are doing something you may not
notice at first they're attacking joe
biden for being weak his weakness is
inviting aggression
and on the basis of that they are in
fact agreeing with biden and supporting
his russia policy got that we're against
biden that's where we're backing him up
in his russia policy
pretty clever
is that what republican voters want
let's see if you ask them they'd
probably say well why don't we send as
much military equipment to the texas
border as we've sent to the russian
border if someone said it out loud then
maybe the entire country could assess
how grotesque washington's priorities
are
speaking to a test priority senator john
cornyn represents texas has for a long
time texas is a state that's had well
over a million foreign nationals pour
into it illegally over the last year
right over the border
that's a far bigger invasion than
anything vladimir putin is planning in
ukraine
and yet when john cornyn talks about
border security
he's not talking about his own state or
even his own country he's talking about
ukrainian border security watch
make no mistake an attack on ukraine is
also an attack on america's global
security interests and on world peace
and could have cascading consequences
that right now
are too horrible to contemplate
this is an existential threat
to our leadership in the world
and to the global order we underwrite
into our way of life and the way of life
of freedom-loving democracies around the
world
freedom-loving democracies around the
world now these are people who sit in
committee meetings often with closed
doors what are they doing well they're
apparently sick in the intel agencies
and anyone who criticizes them but are
they getting unfiltered information from
those intel agencies are they making
wise decisions on the basis of it do
they have any idea what they're talking
about including the man you just saw no
of course not
they cloak their ignorance in the usual
cliches freedom-loving democracies like
ukraine
but the truth is their interests
their beliefs are so far out of
alignment with the interests and beliefs
of the average person in this country
including their own voters that once
that is exposed to light
they're in trouble
last point
this is only happening because there is
no credible opposition to it in the
congress hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else